C sent a guide to me my wife was
pregnant we were living in an apartment
apartment in cat go on CIS skill road we
went through all this I you know and I
was getting ready to move to Staten
Island and we still were there for a
little while before we did you know
after all this went
down he sent a guy to me to the house
secret whatever you want to call it my
wife me
so I listen to
him cuz said if you leave I'm I'm a
messenger you know whatever if you
leave this was in a aftermath of what
the gun the whole thing you got to
remember Tyson was Award of the state he
was put in C's custody cus was looking
to adopt him for obvious reason so he
had control and and he loved
him how dare I say anything less I
won't but it made sense too but he was
awarded of the state still do you know
what that means there's
rules means the state's still
overlooking it if he ain't living the
right life you
know you got to remember he came out of
you know he came out of of a
jail so reform school but if he ain't
living the life he could be taken away
from cus what's not living the right
life well he he wasn't a school no more
they didn't know about it um he he had
some things that were going on we won't
get into that right now in school and
different things
whatever and he had his trainer put a
gun to his head that ain't so good if a
report came back to them that that
happened he would have been taken away
from
cus that couldn't happen nobody knows
this I talk about a little bit but never
probably because why would I I don't
know why am I doing it now I don't know
because I don't know because I am
because it's now because it's now maybe
maybe because it's now I don't know so
he sent this
man that you know obviously we both knew
and he said here's the deal Teddy if no
talk about this wants it to you know
disappear basically you
leave and he will give you 5% his word
can you imagine he would he will give
you 5% of Tyson's earnings for the rest
of his
career and um but I don't regret it one
bit because it wouldn't have happened
anyway see that's where I I could be
honest with my people say oh stand up
guy because I told him shove it with a
you
know you know to in that place and and
um and tell cuz to shove it in that
freaking play you know I was mad um
Teddy Teddy don't get angry don't get
angry are you out of you serious get out
of here here tell him to go shove it
over and you know my wife was like huh
but and then people like after why
didn't you take the deal it wasn't a
deal it was an escape
clause for cuss it was it was a it was
an insurance policy that his you know
that this kid wouldn't be taken away
from and thank God he wasn't I wasn't
going to go and say nothing they didn't
have to worry about cuz forgot who I was
yeah cuz forgot why he went to court for
me because of those because of those
characteristics that he said he loved
and he noticed and that that he
admired I didn't lose those Char he
forgot that that was me he forgot who he
was talking to he didn't have to do
that how about that's why I told him to
shove it up his not because of the other
insult yeah and then and then when
people said to me oh you would stand up
you because it was around a little bit
it it was around in the circles and then
were people oh stand up Teddy he he
didn't care about the money I said stand
up Teddy what are you talking about how
how about how about just realistic Teddy
how about I live in a real world that I
was never going to get that money so I'm
saying I'm standing up to something that
I knew never existed so I ain't stand up
not in that way I am in other ways maybe
but not don't don't put a metal on my
chest for that because because that
never existed yeah it was never meant to
exist but he didn't even understand that
was the one thing that that really
disappointed me in cuss I was like cuz
you really allowed this to get to you
where where you where you've allowed it
to really fog up your thinking to the
point where you're smarter than that
you're better than that that you would
actually think you got a freaking offer
me a
freaking pieces of silver yeah you
really think that that's what you freak
you like all that you told me that you
love me and that we were I was the young
master and that all this and and you
think you were going to buy
me and I was going to and that was going
to keep me quiet how about I would keep
quiet because I would always keep
quiet so he thought maybe you might
betray him isn't that interesting yeah
and why did he think that no no really
fear yeah but yeah fear is the at the
essence of everything is connected with
everything fear of losing what he was
going to lose but it was more than
fear it was him not believing in the
things that he told me he believed
in he didn't even know
that he believed in me because I was a
standup guy because I because I didn't
sell myself because because I you know I
didn't freaking turn evidence I I didn't
make a deal I didn't do and and that's
why he went to court that's why he stood
up for me and I appreciate it and that
was what he lived by and that was his
you know those were the blocks of being
a
man oh so much for those
blocks well it's like you said
loyalty requires uh you know he would
have had to take a
risk on losing immortality that he would
achieve by
Crea and that's the only
way 100% but the only way you ever find
out if somebody is that it's hard is the
test yeah and it was C this is
Shakespearean you know the story C told
me C said and the test come in different
forms yeah I said all right cus this was
his test and and some people pass this
test because they're able to pass that
test because it's not really a test
not for them because it doesn't speak to
their weakness but it's the test that
speaks to the weakness that's the
one so this one I get it I get what it
spoke to cuz you know what at the end of
the day I forgive
you and I feel bad for
you I feel bad that you were put in that
position after you lived your life that
way and that you that you taught that
and you preached that from the
mountaintops that that you had to
be that you had to
be I'm not going to use the word
but that that you had to fail yourself
and that you had to somehow know that
before you died I just pray that you
didn't know that and you still don't
know that because you were great you you
are
great and um and you've given me
something you know you're giving me
something
to to Aspire
towards to try
to try to be less
weak try to be
better and try to be as good as
you wanted to be
I wish I can
someday more importantly I I wish I
could make my
father you
know feel
um just feel good up
there